is a great tool when you start working  in the industry  and definitely it creates a lot of  efficiencies in the process  but i think the danger of using revit in  school is that  it can kind of limit your creativity so  for example  the default wall in revit is like a  two by four stud wall like going  straight up  in architecture school you wanna  challenge the conventional idea of what  a wall is or what a building looks like  so  you know you have to go through extra  steps to design something that has a  slightly more  complex geometry and i've seen  projects change throughout the years  once revit was introduced to schools  so it's definitely something to think  about